hey this is presh tallwalker
abcd is a square
construct the point m alongside a b the
point n alongside bc
then construct a n d m
d n and cm
let p be the intersection of a n with dm
let q be the intersection of a n with cm
and let r be the intersection of cm with
dn
consider one region pqrd that's shaded
in blue
then consider three regions that are
shaded in green these are the sum of the
areas of apm
mqnb
and nrc
the question is
if the area shaded in blue is equal to 1
what is the total area of the regions
shaded in green
i saw this problem via the website cut
the not
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
let's first focus on the area that's
shaded in blue
we want the area of pqrd
we will consider the triangle
adn
we can then find the area of pq rd
by subtracting the areas of triangle adp
and nqr from triangle adn
so now let's calculate the area of
triangle adn
its area is equal to ad multiplied by
its height a b
all over two
but a d times a b
is equal to the area of the square a b c
d
so this is equal to the area of a b c d
all over two
we can substitute this for the area of
adn
we now have an equation for the area of
the region pqrd
let's now put this equation to the side
and focus on the areas of the region
shaded in green
we want to calculate the total area of
the following three regions
we will consider the area in a different
fashion we'll consider the sum of the
areas of triangles adm
and mbc
and then we'll subtract out the areas of
the triangles adp and nqr
this will be equivalent to the total
areas that are shaded in green
now let's calculate the areas of the
triangles adm and mbc
the area of triangle adm
is equal to ad multiplied by am all over
2 and the area of triangle mbc is equal
to ad multiplied by m b all over two
we can now factor and we end up with a d
multiplied by the quantity a m plus m b
all over two
but a m plus m mb is exactly equal to
the length of a b
so the sum of the aries of these two
triangles is equal to a d multiplied by
a b all over two
but a d multiplied by a b is equal to
the area of the square abcd
so the sum of the areas of these two
triangles is exactly equal to half the
area of the square
so we'll substitute that in for the
areas of adm plus mbc
we now have equations
for the areas that are shaded in green
that's the first equation and the area
that's shaded in blue
we'll see both of these are equal to
half the area of the square
minus the area of adp minus the area of
nqr
thus these two equations are equal to
each other
and thus
the green region is exactly equal to the
area of the blue region
thus if the blue region is equal to one
the total of the green areas is also
equal to one
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world problems one video at a
time
you